I've dedicated my life to studying the  ocean but sometimes you come across  something so marvelous you have to  wonder what the heck is going on down  here today we're talking about the mimic  octopus octopus octopuses are rather  curious creatures when exposed they're  vulnerable to predators so typically  they like to stay hidden and when they  do move they do so by walking along the  oceans floor on their eight legs but in  1998 scientists discovered an octopus  residing in the shallow waters of  Indonesia doing something quite strange  over the course of two years they filmed  it and nine other similar octopuses  mimicking behaviors of at least three  different species they found it swimming  its legs outstretched high above the  ocean floor like a lionfish flattened  out gliding over the bottom like a  flatfish and extending its tentacles to  mimic a poisonous sea snake this allows  the mimic octopus to hide in plain sight  astonishing